un passeur de ne pas avoir de réponse
alors lettres 43 familles de la grosne
ont porté plainte contre l'état pour son
inaction environnementale elles ont donc
décidé d'agir collectivement en
saisissant la justice un recours
collectif a été déposée devant le
tribunal administratif de lyon
objectif contraindre le préfet à agir
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique et protéger ainsi leurs
enfants de ses effets une pétition a
aussi été lancée elle a recueilli à ce
jour soixante dix neuf mille signatures
pour en parler nous sommes avec florence
davroux membres du collectif parents
pour la planète à l'origine de cette
action en justice
bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france vous avez donc déposé
hier
ce recours pour pousser la préfecture à
agir qu'attendez vous concrètement et
bien bonjour à tous ce qu'on attend
concrètement en fait c'est que le préfet
fasse son travail puisque les lois
européennes et les lois françaises
l'obligent à travailler sur la
protection de l'environnement sur la
protection de l'air des sols arables
nous nous demandons ce justement qu'il
fasse son travail puisque les lois
existent et qu'on voudrait en fait
qu'elle soit appliquée au niveau de la
drôme et au delà bien sûr vous avez déjà
adressé une lettre au préfet c'était au
mois d'août
vous êtes resté sans réponse aujourd'hui
cette action voilà ce recours en justice
quelle autre action pouvez vous
envisager alors ya des manifestations
régulièrement avec les jeunes pour la
planète donc nous participons à ces
manifestations
et puis surtout en fait nous proposons à
d'autres citoyens voire d'autres parents
de france de faire ce même type d'action
en fait dans toute la france en
proposant un kit de démarrage pour les
aider à monter ses actions et d'ailleurs
il ya débat des citoyens du lot qui ont
créé une association juillet dernier et
qui vont déposer au même le recours aux
prêts
de leur préfet de région alors dernière
question est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler les risques à l'heure actuelle
du réchauffement climatique pour la
planète et des conséquences justement
sur les enfants alors nous en fait on
agit bien au niveau de territoire
on agit sur notre territoire sur la
drôme on pointe du doigt en fait ce qui
ne va pas au niveau de la drôme est pas
au niveau général du réchauffement
climatique
donc nous ce qu'on a pointé avec notre
avocate
c'est la pollution de l'air la pollution
de l'eau la baisse de la biodiversité et
l'artifice ation des sols très bien en
tout cas merci beaucoup florence à
davroux d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes membre du
collectif parents pour la planète